see
fire so again this is from last night
this is from just after midnight
on would be april 17th yep
in portland
so if we go uh is there sound zach
okay so uh if i can be heard over this
just describing to people who are merely
listening
um we've just got you know street view
shots of
here's a dumpster that is smoldering
closed it's probably on fire we don't we
can't see that for sure
we saw that dumpster this morning it was
definitely i know we're going we're
getting there
okay we're talking about last night it's
all one street
and so we have store closing everything
must go with an
entirely borrowed up street and then if
you go back uh to the last one
you see right next door um an anarchy
sign an
a-cap all caps are about all cops or
bastards and several other things which
are visible in the in the larger
photograph but um not here so
um i want to come back to my other
photos but not now because
i want to show them at the end of what
you want to show so here
this is exactly adjacent to the
apple store and you see something that
has become very common
here in portland downtown so you've had
windows busted up they are they have
plywood or osb put over them and then
these spontaneous murals go up and the
murals are of various different kinds
some of them are accusations
some of them are designed to portray the
uh the protesters as
uh peace loving and creative so
presumably we're gonna show a bunch of
these murals like that there are a lot
right a lot of numbers but
many of them have high production values
yeah like actually beautiful street art
that you know if if if there was a place
to put it that wasn't about having
smashed windows and so put wood up in
its place
um i think that there could could
legitimately be a place for this sort of
art in
a functioning city yeah although i would
say you know you have talented people
but
the the fact that somebody is able to
put up something colorful
and load whatever payload into it they
wish and that this somehow speaks for
the people of portland is
absolutely appalling so even though some
of the murals
may say things that uh one could
resonate with a lot of them
really don't and you know either you
need some sort of
authority to decide what sentiments can
be represented even if you were going to
have some place where
street art could uh could be put up by
by citizens and then the problem is all
right who decides what sentiment
is going to go where yeah so this one
you can't see
the third uh frame of this mural what it
says and it's also hard to read
but what it how it reads um if you're
looking straight on is if my heart stops
turning
will the world do the same
and this strikes me as like okay hearts
don't turn
forget the you know basic biological
innumeracy or whatever it is
um no worries on that front but um
i i feel like the
the initiative behind the sentiment is a
desire
to have to know that if someone if their
heart stops beating
uh the whole world will stop right and
uh it reveals this level of narcissism
uh absent
any apparent desire to fix things or to
make things right
um it is entirely about me
in the moment and destruction right and
this actually
goes to the the heart
of the misunderstanding here which is
in some sense the puzzle is about
whatever we are
continuing into the future and the
attack
on these structures makes it
very likely that this system and all
those who depend on it will not
meaningfully continue into the future we
will be subjugated by someone else or
will be overrun by some civilization
that didn't lose its mind
and so watching people who conflict
their own well-being who
basically demand that the world stop if
they do
is preposterous a reasonable person
understands that you are rooting
for your people whoever they are
irrespective of whether you're present
if you died tomorrow do you stop
caring about the people that you love no
you're rooting for them and
suddenly they're hobbled by the fact
that they don't have your
insight or help in uh in
dealing with the the challenges of life
but it doesn't
change your sense about whether or not
you know things matter things matter
whether or not you're there
and so they've lost they've lost sight
of this completely
so where i was hoping to go to first
though was just you know
was the apple store on fire did the
apple store burn to the ground
um i know you have some pictures of that
i'd like us to show those to
to respond to you know just social media
at the moment
is as usual after these things happen
completely polarized
um and um and
we were just there we actually talked to
one of the workers who was working on
cleaning up the
so zach can you show uh one of the
pictures from the um
yeah there you go it's a little dark
unfortunately but let's describe it so
we're looking at the same mural that you
were just looking at up close
there's a dumpster out in front that has
clearly been burned we can show you that
up close in a second
and then to the right there you see
barricades
which are around the apple store
which was being renovated and by the
dumpster
is the awning that they apparently set
fire like the dumpster is under the
awning they set fire to that
the awning's gone the tree is burned um
and the dumpster was apparently inside
the uh
um in inside the uh apple store compound
as were the um bathrooms um that were
there for the workers to
fix the repairs from the previous riots
right and the bathrooms got burned to
the ground
so um so anyway yes the apple compound
did burn the building did not burn to
the ground nor is it
very conceivable that it could given
what it's built out of but nonetheless
there apple was targeted here yeah
and a lot of damage was done
that apple's got on the outside i don't
have it ready i took it but i
didn't capture it but uh could you show
the mural
on the apple store so i want to describe
something here so this mural is no
longer on the apple store but it is
worth understanding
uh its history in order to understand
uh or to put in context the events of
last night
so the apple store i believe was being
renovated for its own reasons
and was open for one day post-renovation
and then it was shut down by covid in
the aftermath of being shut down by
covid
it was uh attacked during riots
windows were broken people broke in and
then
apple decided to put up basically a
black
wall um all around a plywood
wall and then
on that wall a local artist
spontaneously
put up a mural focused on george floyd
and the famous
line i can't breathe and apple
decided to leave the mural in place many
other artists
then contributed to the mural and
ultimately
the mural was donated by apple
to don't shoot pdx which is a local
police watch group now currently
on the outer fence of the apple compound
there
is a sign heather you have it you want
to read it yeah i really i wanted i
thought we were going to show this
yes please uh so it reads apple stands
with you in the fight for racial and
social justice black lives matter
the community it's not in those pictures
zach i just sent it to you
um the community artwork has been
entrusted to don't shoot portland in
support of their mission for social
change
don't shoot portland a local black-led
human rights non-profit organization
will incorporate the artwork
as part of their children's art and
social justice council programming
for more information visit
www.donshootpdx.org
and there's another one that um i was
not the one who photographed it
um that's even more sort of it's it's
again
one of these don't hurt me walls and so
apple not only is putting money to
in the other one they indicate they're
sending that they're putting money
towards
these causes and um and this is the
response
right so i i want to um
hone that to a slightly sharper point
yeah
apple this is your fault you did this to
us
you caused this riot now it may be that
it would have happened without your help
but it certainly did happen
with your help and the fact that you are
pretending
that uh people attacking your store and
you having to put up plywood and that
creating an opportunity for a local
artist to express
express a sentiment that i don't think
represents us universally
and then you treat this as something
that has to be honored
is creating the problem and basically we
have
you know runaway woke capital and woke
capital has you know the back end the
business end where it does whatever it
does
financially speaking and it has the
front end where it coddles this kind of
sentiment in public
and god damn it the problem with the
don't hurt me walls
is that what don't hurt me really means
is go hurt somebody else so apple
not only did you have this coming
because you set us up for it but the
rest of us who did not have it coming
got it too
as a result of your activity
[Music]